got Apatow we were just talking about 10
years ago Superbad came out you were the
producer of that movie thanks for
joining us jug when's the first time you
saw the script on Superbad I see the
script of suited up it was like talked
about in the halls of Freaks and Geeks
except I was going to have her writing
or something basically read it during a
declared except reading it was with the
captain undeclared and then he aged out
aged out and decided he needed younger
people to play the place has been
evident so became a cop uh the role of
McLovin how did that come up and it's
based on somebody who you know is that
it's actual person named McLovin that
these guys knew well phase we're looking
for somebody and we were looking for
real kid so we thought there wasn't kids
who would be right probably don't think
they could be actors or have agents and
so the transit director put out like
flyers at certain high schools and so
now Christians plus the table where this
flyer you came in and I think [ __ ] I was
handed about this that he was Anne
Tolley at the first audition as he was
in the movie like he just did it exactly
right and there's the first that he ever
did and he shall give children a job
after addition said don't hire that guy
he had believes me if he actually
authorities you you must be perfect and
then Joe the fell in love with it but he
was going to Joe the heart of the
audition it's assaulted here that it
brought success but who came up with
McLovin you have a fake light ID with
one name in your from Hawaii well that
did it salts up such a hazard at eleven
I guess based on those layers
it's a nice floor and they used all your
beams and as opposed to basically are
the actual millions of their breads we
didn't see that covent attacked
airplanes to be serviceable spirit what
did you know that you had in Jonah Hill
at the time
well except we just went to the movies
and kid I know how easy chocolate this
kid said hey I'm auditioning for your
movie tomorrow and he and he came in
lead for the 40 old version for one line
and our casting director Allison Johnson
yeah this guy's great and then the day
we shot is seeing with cavitating gets
so much free time but just to punish Joe
no no it was just 18 or 19
we made him improvise a really long time
Kedar just cuz kita was so awesome she
so love it's a little scary when I get
some force in the improv with her and so
we did it he was really funny and then
he kept putting forward more of it in
the footage opportunity the more we
added the more he kills and he realized
that you know that he was great and we
thought it was too old
this is that then one day you know we
couldn't figure out how to play that
part because it may be Jonah's not too
old to play it go shave shave and we
said okay I guess you can't do it
what's your favorite scene in Superman
my favorite scene cigarette oh my god I
mean I I think the thing that's your
uncle about it is you know almost
everything is really really fun i i i
always liked the sweet scenes you know I
like I like to laugh a where the he goes
down the escalator and him and Michael
Cera separate with the different girls
of Emmett and Martha and that's probably
my favorite part and you look back and
you forget Emma Stone was in that movie
it's like I was watching a house
last night I go on I tried Emma Stone
was in House Bunny and then all of a
sudden here she is the highest-paid
actress in Hollywood today I know I
carry me with with her yeah at the time
what we're looking for was someone who
would subs that character like who's the
cool girl at school who would be able to
identify that that character that Jenna
place is awesome but no one else would
realize that and it was ever well I go
back to the easy a and that's when you
know you saw something different in her
eye you know I mean obviously you can
look at her now but I remember the easy
a and I thought she was great and caring
that it was it smart to not do a sequel
to super bad or was there temptation oh
no it was a terrible idea
everybody a beggar girl I said you
should do the show where Michael Sarah's
at college and Jonah shows up and starts
sleeping on the couch College won't
leave because his life isn't going well
and I begged everybody everyone's like
no you don't want to ruin the fact that
this thing is perfect why would you want
to risk that next one would be bad and I
said well that's like if you made one
episode of The Sopranos and let's not
make it worse were afraid we can't make
another good one I'm still serious your
life is not complete you're angry
I'm very angry ma'am hey congrats on on
allowing us to reminisce obviously you
had fun doing it and launched some
careers there as well but thanks for
joining us John Karloff loves it i jut
out the town writer director producer
and married to one of my favorite
actresses Leslie Mann she's good she's
great the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you